hello everybody
welcome to a very special episode of the
witching hour we
are presenting for north bend film fest
with the uh director and cast of
superior
i am so delighted to be joined by
director
aaron vasilopoulos and stars alessandra
and animesa
thank you guys thanks for having us so
much for having us
absolutely and so i wanted to tee up the
film
a little bit for our listeners who may
not have attended the festival but i
also don't know how much you
don't want to give away so if if one of
you would give me your
preferred synopsis that would be great
yeah so i usually describe the film
superior
as a sort of thriller drama hybrid
about identical twin sisters who
reconnect
when one sister returns to their
hometown
on the run to hide out i've seen it i
really liked it it's a beautiful movie
i want to definitely dive into the uh
you know cinematography element of it in
a bit but we do always kind of like to
go back to the beginning a little bit
uh on the witching hour and i want to
talk to all of you about that but for
alessandra and annie it is not
let's say super common for even
siblings but twins to want to get into
the same
industry of acting and um curious what
age did you guys realize you both wanted
to do that and how did that come about
for you
we started doing uh theater together
late in high school and we i think both
became really obsessed with it and never
wanted to leave the theater
um and i think we both kind of uh
held on to different aspects that we
have carried into our adulthood i think
like
my sister loves being in process with
different people and collaborating and
um and i do as well but i've also been
you know
very focused on like the acting element
so we we kind of have like
a certain balance between the two of us
that we're like we're doing the same
thing but we have a kind of
uh yin and yang together um
but yeah at the end of high school
did you find that both of you wanting to
partake in it
only further fueled that interest in the
art of acting
yeah i think just being able to talk we
became obsessed with it
at first it actually first started out
technically
in eighth grade because my cousin was
afraid to go to her summer camp alone
and so she convinced us the night before
her summer camp to go to camp with her
and it was like this theater camp and
we didn't really have a specific
interest in theater we just were like
yeah we'll go with you
and we i just from that just completely
loved it kept doing it
as often as we could and then started
getting more into
film and i think i think that
once we started getting more into film
and and watching movies
we became very obsessed and
um that's became kind of all we would
talk about at that point
but yeah we feel we were feeling each
other for sure
and for you erin when did you like first
discover that passion
i don't know if it was a particular film
you saw that made you realize you want
to do that and at what point
did you decide to like pursue that more
professionally and go all the way to
grad school
yeah um it was a bit of a roundabout
process for me
i was a bit older um when i finally
decided to go to film school
um it's not like i grew up knowing that
i wanted to be a filmmaker anything like
that
um and i think eventually what it was
for me was
just like getting a camera like i i was
always
obsessed with film and like watch tons
of movies growing up
and through college and i was sort of on
a
path to wanting to like curate film
something like in a museum setting or
something like that and then i ended up
moving to
spain for a couple years i was living in
madrid teaching
for a couple years and got a little
camera over there
and that was the first time i actually
started like shooting stuff
and starting to edit and like pairing
stuff with music
and um i do think in a lot of ways those
experiences
eventually like combined with my sort of
long-standing interest in film
that was enough to like convince me that
i should apply to film school and that
this
it sort of really felt like something
that combined
a range of my interests also in writing
and
um sort of like visual art
design um just felt like all those
things kind of came together
in filmmaking and
inspired me to apply to film school and
go to film school
and so correct me if this is wrong i
believe that you
all attended nyu and this came about
as a project at nyu correct yes
excellent so it we often ask like the
follow-up of
what did film school give you or was it
worth it and what was
what did you get from it it's very
obvious here that this like
going to graduate school directly led
you guys to this project
but i'm curious outside of that
what did each of you take from that
education
experience and you know whether it's
it's networking or the way you approach
your art
was there something bigger and grander
than the
obvious it led us here today very
specifically
my sister and i both studied acting in
school for me it was like
a time of discovery for me just to
figure out who i was as an artist and
meeting
a lot of my people and a lot of the
artists that i still work with today
including aaron um
and yeah for me the huge huge benefit of
of going to school was just uh
the people that i met and the teachers
that i was able to
have that changed the way i saw
art you know being in new york city is
one of my favorite parts of having gone
to nyu is just like
the amount of characters that you meet
along the way and you can like bring it
into your work it's just such a
global city um and
yeah the community i'm i
am such a fan of uh creating an ensemble
of people that you continue to work with
and uh i think just having a group of
you know like-minded people around at
nyu just you gravitate towards
certain people and some people you want
to hold on to and
you know i'm i'm grateful to have found
a few so it's definitely community like
it's definitely the collaborators that i
met
in in film school and um like our dps
we actually ended up working together on
our very first
student short in grad school and then
she shot the short film
and eventually the future and we still
work together and
um so yeah definitely like the people
that i met
not just in my class but like in the
years
sort of ahead and below me and um
there's still like a lot of crossover
with
people i'm meeting today and reaching
out to today and
i think that was definitely like in
terms of those
relationships that you built obviously
this is a very functional and thriving
creative dynamic you've built with each
other and from your
perspective aaron i believe you you
wrote the
short film superior without having met
them
and then you came back to write the
feature
and you co-wrote it with alessandra so
i'm curious from your perspective the uh
you know approaching the same characters
first from having not known your stars
and then kind of
building up again from not just
knowing them but having one on board
writing there was quite a big
time jump between the two um but it did
feel quite different
um and i think we were exploring we're
exploring like a little bit
different things in in the future
superior i mean the themes carry over
but i think with the short
it was really about sort of like the
growing pains between
teenage identical twins and sort of
specifically the moment one sister is
wanting to distinguish herself
um there's a lot i think a little more
like tension
and i think the performance style is
also like slightly different
um so like
i don't know but um it definitely
like informed our jumping off point to a
large degree when ollie and i got
together and we started
talking about the possibility of a
feature and outlining
um and yeah we were mostly just excited
to sort of like fill in that
backstory of we love the idea of
creating this jump
in time so that the future picks up six
years later
um and
yeah the short was definitely like a
interesting
prologue to be able to like use as a
sort of jumping off point for that
process
but we also i think gave ourselves
room to sort of like experiment and open
it up to something new and i think
especially like the thriller elements of
the
feature feel quite different to me um
and that's yeah that was a big part of
the writing process so
and then i'll let these two speak to the
fact that like their relationship also
informs a lot of
i think the script and um there's some
specific
instances of that and then but i think
just more broadly um
i had a lot to bring to the table and
with the feature
um being a twin herself obviously
it feels kind of like a natural thing
to bring to the table but um yeah yeah
um
i think um with the feature you know we
we started writing it and like within
within the first day we had like a full
outline of what
what kind of the direction that we
wanted to take
when we had first decided to meet to
write something we didn't
even we weren't specifically thinking
that we were gonna
do a continuation of the short that was
never something that was
brought up or thought of or it was kind
of like open-ended and
and it just immediately became all about
this and
um we pretty much knew where it was
going from the start which i think is
really special
you also had the opportunity to return
to
as you say evolved in a different angle
on but characters you had pre-released
previously established a few years later
which you
really usually only see like in
franchise filmmaking
so uh how how is that for you guys as
performers and did your
sort of relationships to your characters
also change over that time
yeah that was really really special um
as as a as a writer to do that with a
character that already
like existed and that i've been able to
play and also as an actor yeah it was
it was a really amazing experience and
and the characters
changed a lot between the two films um
but it's always nice as an actor to have
that like
kind of built-in backstory because
that's kind of part of your work anyway
so yeah it was really nice to have
uh i think aaron put it really well when
she said it was like a jumping off point
i think like
having the foundation and the backstory
allowed for more getting more
imaginative when it came to like
the characters and how they've evolved
and you know
kind of like being able to paint kind of
like broader pictures
of these characters um and we i think we
just we had a lot of
fun with the characterization of them uh
i think you guys did too in the in the
writing of it and that that was just
like on the page
um but i think that there's also a
certain level of uh comfort and just an
ability to communicate
directly between the three of us that we
were also able to
um develop so by the time the feature
came around we were
you know making kind of braver
choices and and and feeling more like
you know
uh comfortable in the creative process
yeah i do think having just to add one
more thing
having the short it was definitely sort
of i think we were all just so excited
about that whole world too
and the characters and um it definitely
helped serve as sort of like a
foundation throughout the whole process
of making the future
um to have that just drawn
i think that um aaron you've spoken
about that your original idea for the
short
had had come from growing up around
twins and i think
you guys probably know from first-hand
experience there is in fact a lot of
fascination around twins
um was that an interesting thing for you
guys to
explore and have you know like
guardianship over
in a feature film i mean i don't
i don't have to tell you it can be
exploitative and weird and so like
uh was that empowering in some way
i remember the first i i remember when i
first
read the short thinking how
awesome it was that there was a project
about twins where we weren't like in a
circus
or like very like fetishized or
yeah it was it was amazing and and
that's
that's been a special part about this
project
all along um but i i remember distinctly
having that feeling like
like we had found like a diamond in the
rough with this project
when we were working on the short yeah i
also feel like you know
just because we're twins we just think
like you know twins are
people like anyone else like i think if
we were characterizing them
just as sisters we would have kind of
given them the same
i think we focused you know on giving
them like their individuality and
care and i think that's um maybe from
like our own struggle and our own quest
for
individuality um yeah so i think that
that informed a lot of it and a lot of
the themes of the movie
being about identity independence
this is highly tied into identity and
and
the you know the differences and shared
ground between these
characters and uh you know eventually
sort of transmuting those things into
your performances at a certain point
how do you approach playing your
twin sister who is playing a character
like that seems like a little bit of a
head [ __ ] maybe
like how did you get into exchanging
those personas while you're also working
within your own lived experiences
uh i it was definitely a mindfuck i
think
um in in a lot of ways it's uh not only
did we have to
distinguish i wanted to make sure that
we distinguished we all did one
distinguish between the two characters
but also
there are certain elements um in the
characters that are
like very different from who we are
naturally so there was like
a lot of navigating to do and we knew
that the switch was coming up in the
movie so we wanted to make sure that
they were
you know distinct enough that that could
be like pulled off without being
confusing or
anything like that's for me that's where
part of my focus was
yeah for me the the switching
um felt was wasn't that was it wasn't
very it was
it was a very kind of when
because i had as marian
been spending time with vivian
on set and getting to know this
character that
my sister had built through my character
when the switch came it was kind of like
i think at first i was like
you know in my head like oh oh no like
this this this might be
really tough you know i was i was
nervous about about that element of it
but then at one point i realized you
know
marian is not a professional actor
and she is just trying to be
as much like her sister as possible so
that's
that kind of calmed me down and also
i think i think helped because i think
at one point
i was trying to like make it such a
perfect
like impression and i was like that's
not really
realistic you know and so
then after i had that like little
breakthrough then
it all became kind of easier
it became more of like a game for for
marion
that's such a good point and i have to
say i was really nervous about that
aspect of the story too but like i also
think
just the tone of the world like allowed
for that
in a way you did such a good job of like
walking this line between
it being kind of comical and
still ground like grounded enough i
think um where
it works but um
yeah no you guys you nailed it and like
i think that's totally right marines
she wouldn't have been like a seamless
totally seamless
performer and part of what i love about
your performances is like seeing that
seeing your interpretation of that
something else i really love about kind
of what you're talking about the
the overlapping of more comedic elements
and there is the
the thriller baseline but also
somehow while satisfying all those
things you guys make time
for really quiet character beats like i
think about the moment with the ice
cream
and stuff like that um what is
what is the deciding factor whether it's
when you're writing it or in the edit
of why something like that stays
more commercial films often don't take
that time for really quiet small
character beats and is there ever an
impulse to think well maybe it's more
marketable if we if we streamline and
keep it straight thriller
yeah i know i'm glad you're bringing
this up because it is i think a big part
of the story is like these different
tones and
um i think that we had a lot of fun with
that when we were writing and definitely
wanted it to be this sort of very much
like hybrid of
genres um so yeah a lot of that came i
think in writing
but then in in editing i will say it was
like
a little bit of a challenge to then sort
of make sure we were balancing on all of
the tones
um because they do swing
quite a bit like between the comical and
then like especially thriller elements
but um yeah the our editor gen rock was
really instrumental in
sort of figuring that out and using
sound and music to sort of help
create like a more cohesive palette for
everything
um it was to a large degree how the
opening of the film
sort of evolved the way it did with the
inner cutting that was something that
really came
in in the edit and feeling like we
needed to sort of
establish these two worlds of each
sister the sort of
thriller through line that marion was
coming from and then
like domestic sort of slightly more
comedic stilted um
tone of vivian's world um
we didn't have those two things in our
cup quite as much in the
opening of the of the script as written
um what was your other oh
was that how intentional was yeah i
don't know
i don't think i think a lot of that was
just intuitive
as we were writing um yeah i think that
i think that you naturally as a director
are okay with
taking your time and um
setting a very specific pace um that i
think that is like
natural within you um which i think is
beautiful
and um but yeah as far as
as the tones that was something we were
very aware of when we were writing
you know like these these two very
different worlds that eventually were
going to collide
like we had to start out at like very
very different
different places and kind of be like how
how were these gonna tie in to get
what's gonna happen you know that was
that was definitely
part of it from from my perspective i
also felt like
part of that came from the combination
of year two writing styles
i mean i don't know if that's like yeah
it was intentional but it's also
you know it's two different minds coming
together and and like there was a
there was a clear like a and and it it
also
even it lived within the characters too
that same duality
they they're coming from different
worlds that are you know and they've
been separate for
seven years and now are now coming
together so there's like that natural
evidence between the two so as i
promised i'm gonna have to talk about
the
cinematography a bit because it is a
beautiful looking movie
um how do you convince producers to let
you shoot on 16 millimeter
oh my gosh that's a good question
honestly
i got so lucky with that um with this
project
um i really didn't i just like didn't
know if it was gonna be possible
um because it is so expensive and it's
just
like the process takes so much more time
um but yeah they honestly i have to say
we're pretty much on board
right away with that idea because they
just
saw the short and like sort of reading
the feature through the lens of the
short
they were like we you know we see that
this needs to be
a continuation we want this to feel like
a continuation of that world
and then also the fact that um we
decided to set the feature
um in the 80s like specifically in the
80s i think everybody agreed that
film would really help um
help us just sort of build that feeling
um
without having like a huge budget for
like production design
and um that the film would really like
um
just lend itself to and sort of 80s
quality
than digitality um so
yeah just really lucky with our
producers kind of getting all of that
from the beginning
to say i was even more impressed knowing
that it was shot on film
like even more impressed by the
commitment to taking time for smaller
moments knowing that each one of those
moments was literally burning film like
you can't just
shoot infinite right like you can that
was such a wild experience too as an
actor to like
be shooting on film and know that like
once everything goes
right you have like one or two takes you
know because it's you know it's a
low budget environment but also we're
shooting on film and
you know things are yeah there's like a
garden for you for the actors because
it's like you just get sort of put into
this like
it just creates a little more like
rigidity um
and i mean i think that's helpful
sometimes
i feel like it sort of elevates the
experience
but it's also like a little bit higher
states
i personally love the adrenaline of it
so to me it was like there's a certain
like immediacy and an
adrenaline that gave me a lot and i
i i loved it i imagine you guys weren't
doing a lot of
riffing
there was some improv in some little
moments but no for the most part we were
sticking to the script
i would say if there were and if there
was any riffing done it was in the ice
cream shop
you opted to set it in the 80s in part
for you know the sort of
aesthetic and tone but once you made
that decision did you find that it
influenced the narrative and
storytelling in specific ways
there were like a lot of reasons i think
why we gravitated towards the 80s
partially because the short already kind
of had that feel it wasn't specifically
80s but
it sort of felt like it or like kind of
in any time
any place kind of aesthetic but i mean i
do remember
when we were first talking about the
future like
i just always like being able to write
um sort of
like miscommunicate and sort of like
mixed messages across
paths and like this is just so much
harder to do
with like modern technology
um yeah it's kind of a boring detail but
like i do think
that was sort of like when we were
writing it allowed us to
just like have a lot more sort of like
misunderstandings
and mix-ups between characters yeah and
these characters are so disconnected for
so long and i don't think that would
happen in the same way today no
yeah i was thinking about that as well
like you may not have spoken for several
years but you probably know what was up
for me personally like the seclusion
like the small town feel
like it helped build like the kind of
like mundaneness of
of everyday life and also like yeah the
complete mystery of what's been going on
with my sister and and even help like
aaron said like building the tension
um throughout the story and and allowing
for miscommunications mishaps and
not everything's just like a quick text
a way of solve as a quick text and
oh that's we solved the problem
nowhere to go now i think that's a
really good point but
yeah without that the characters are
much more like isolated
yeah that's definitely a big part of the
story erin you spoke about
how you reworked the intro a little bit
to combine like the feelings of those
two different worlds and i'm curious
how you worked with your dp
mia chaffee okay
yeah um to to establish those
different worlds and then ultimately how
you
reframed it as the film moved on to sort
of blend them more together
um yeah that was definitely a big
challenge um
and i think we just we had like pretty
different references for each
sort of thread the thriller thread and
the drama and sort of the domestic
sphere
um i think for like marion's story
we knew that we wanted that to feel a
little bit more like
warish and like we kind of were looking
at some like
jollo horror stuff um references
so we wanted that to feel a lot more
even
like even the whole film is pretty
heightened but we wanted that to feel
sort of
even more heightened and stylized um
and i think like more shadowy like we
used
a little bit like harsher lighting more
contrast
and then in the house we
we went pretty crazy with like colors in
the house
um that became a big part of like sort
of that
tone um and i think i think
afterwards people have pointed out like
a comparison to like
um all the almodovar which like i hadn't
been thinking about but like
now i see that and i'm like that's
pretty interesting
and i i like that connection um
although i don't know the colors almost
like add to the
sort of like confinement of vivian's
world and
it's like a little bit deranged the
whole thing
i think that palette the greens and like
reds that we
that we had in the house um but also
yeah in terms of shooting we also talked
a lot about like um
having more static shots in the house
wanting the house to feel kind of
again like like characters were kind of
stuck there
and a little bit stifled whereas um
with marion's through line and like
especially robert starting to show up in
the house
we decided to go a little more handheld
and like
try to create sort of ruptures in that
stillness
um so we were often thinking about ways
that um
those moments would sort of break into
the stillness of the house and sort of
the stability of the house or
another benefit of the 80s and your
commitment to
bright stylized color are the stunning
costumes
they are so especially anything you guys
wear that's red
is like i would i would wear that it's
beautiful well i am curious about the
the heavy use of red does that make
things more
challenging to feature so much red in a
shot i know that's kind of a goofy
really fundamental rudimentary question
but
it's a really bold punchy colors and
there's a lot of them in the costuming
yeah um that's an interesting question i
think
mia would have like more opinions on
that
i do remember she was like
she was a little nervous about the green
walls in the house
and red like combining that with red um
i think for like skin tones
but in general i think red shows up
pretty well on film
actually i think digitally it can be a
little trickier
um i don't know that for sure but i
i just feel like it like when you
compress
things like red can start to get kind of
crunchy digitally but like
i don't know in my experience i'm
obsessed with the red and
it was a big part of the short and um
i don't know i always love the way it
looks
um i can't think of any other scenes
where it felt like a challenge
specifically but maybe that is why it's
so striking to me because
red is not an uncommon color for
clothing but it is
so striking in this movie maybe it is
not filming yeah
yeah i feel like in in this movie
there's
um when when red is used there's usually
like
some kind of danger or like for
for me like vivian's red dress is like
she's like pursuing
her passion and it leads her into danger
and i i don't know i feel like
uh the red jumpsuit in the beginning too
is like
you're just like automatically you're
like something's
something's the you know something's
there's some danger in the air
um and i i felt that way when i was when
i was wearing it
it like helped me feel you know like i
was like we're leading up to
to what the ending was and yeah
there's like blood passion
i think at some point we also because of
the dogs and the wolves we started
talking about like
little red riding hood and yeah we were
definitely
yeah no our our costume designer that
was a big conversation was like how
marion sort of brings the red into
vivian's world
or like vivian had sort of put away the
red and then it comes out again
shows up and then those two things
eventually kind of
crisscross and bleed into one
something i another curious about
because a lot of short films are more
proof of concept and then it becomes
like a more faithful retelling of that
in a feature length this was sort of
like more
proof of character and obviously not the
same exact story
so what was behind the decision to keep
the same title
we thought about other titles at the end
uh
sort of like while we were editing but
i don't know i felt like it still
really applied and i think any and all
they backed me up on that
um because it was sort of like like what
the future became was in some ways sort
of the inverse of this short like this
short was sort of about
growing pains and like in the end this
feeling that the sisters might
sort of be going their own going on
their own paths for a while and like
it was sort of about the tension between
these power dynamics
so superior in that sense sort of to me
like spoke to
some of those themes and those feelings
but in the future it's really like
sort of more about um the realization
that
these sisters are like stronger together
than the part and that
is you know in that way they're sort of
like
superior or stronger it's a very strong
word
very loaded word um
yeah we also had some backstory with
the place superior wisconsin which is
just like a little
anecdote um and i'm from minnesota and
like when i wrote the short
i was sort of obsessed with this town
that's on um
on lake superior in northern wisconsin
so i actually wanted to
originally wanted to film the short
there and then
because it was kind of crazy to like try
to bring everybody from new york
to wisconsin ended up location scouting
upstate and finding
similar towns but then when i met annie
and ollie it turns out
their family they're you guys can tell
your cuban family lived in superior
yeah so my grandparents um lived in
superior
um and my my dad grew up there for a few
years
and it's like a very very tiny town
so the chances of that happening it was
a strange connection
yeah so i think we all just felt kind of
like that
also was in the sort of in the
background of the title
there's like a certain natural
competition bits
between siblings and and like you said
like that
we end up realizing that we're the the
the strongest
when we're together but there's like uh
there's there's something especially in
the future to me that like you know
we've
we've
grown apart so it's like you know which
way of life is like is like
you know the right way there's like a
and i think
both of them end up um feeling like they
can
learn something from each other and in
the switching they do
and then maybe find out that neither is
really superior and that
what they're better to get something
else that
you do that i love is you said this
movie again halloween
and i was reading some of your previous
interviews and it seems that that was
not an easy choice to hold on to because
you ran into winter when it was in fact
very snowy and cold
so what was it about that setting that
that made you want to go through all
that hassle to maintain it
yeah it was really important to me um
i don't know i just love halloween like
always
as a kid it was just like so big for me
and
i'm just obsessed with halloween and
like um
i liked i think ali and i also talked a
lot when we were writing about like
it's just i just liked you know there
are a lot of like
thrillers or or maybe set around
halloween
i liked this sort of like the inner play
that we could
kind of create with some like the horror
movie on tv
and some of the costumes and i felt like
it added like an interesting echo
to what each sister was going through
and
and some of the themes we'd already
established and yeah just the themes of
identity too
on like the one day of the year where
you can kind of be whoever you want to
be
yeah and then that i think like what
really
like made halloween really important to
me was
when marion is is walking home
i mean vivian is walking home as as
marian on halloween night
and she's just like they're she's seeing
like all these
little kids also dressed up in costume
but in a way she's also dressed up in a
costume
we keep coming back to this theme of
identity
and it is something that i i'm really
curious
um alessandra and ani in your
as you're establishing individual
careers in a very competitive business
while also
collaborating with each other how do you
guys find
the balance between you know like
growing and creating
together but also establishing those
individual paths
yeah i think it's an ongoing journey um
i think that
we're kind of figuring it out as we go
along as of now
what's been working is we work on things
individually and we work on things
together
and that's okay you know and then we
help each other with
whatever else we're working on
independently if we need another eye on
it or whatever but
yeah i think like with a new
relationship you know you you can
really be the best uh
partner or collaborator when you have
the fullness of identity within yourself
and
um you have the time and space
to find out who you are on your own and
then you can
both have something to bring to it i
think that's something that in
recent times we've we've been um
we've been doing and i see
a lot of benefits to that in the work
that we come together and are able to do
um because we both have like a separate
um
fullness we balance each other out in a
lot of ways
we are here at north bend but we are
obviously not
here at north bend i miss you northland
what a lovely place to be and i wish i
was there but
um you guys and aaron you told me before
we started
you guys have not actually been at a
screening together yet
so what what has your your journey with
this film through the festival circuit
been like are there so like is there a
surprise
pro to having it come out in this
virtual circuit or is it all sash
uh it's not all sad i mean we premiered
at sundance and um i think they did a
great job
with the virtual platform and i mean to
me the biggest
like silver lining of that was that our
families and like friends and other
places
got to see the premiere and that was
honestly really exciting and
um i think i've talked to some people
since then that
just yeah like thought it was actually
pretty cool that
it sort of democratized the festival in
a way that
like these are so many people who can't
afford to go to sundance or like just
wouldn't
um you know it's an it's kind of a
bubble in a lot of ways so
i think that was the best thing i was
getting to share that experience with
um more people but
it's been kind of sad like i don't know
it's weird to not have sat in a theater
like i've started going to movies again
in new york and it's
so great and it's like yeah i mean i
really look forward to getting to do
that
um hopefully with cass and
some of our crew eventually sitting in
an audience together and
having that experience i know you asked
about the positive things but i did
i do feel like it i did really miss out
on
feeling like we could all celebrate
together and like you know like
hold each other like just that's like
just something from this year that
now i'm like i just i want contact like
i just want to be
with people and experiencing it in in
the energy together and
so it's sad not to be able to do that
but at the same time we were you know
uh it does open up like we're all able
to be in completely different places on
our own journeys and
still come together for an hour and
be able to talk and and do the events
you know yeah i think that when it does
happen it'll it'll make it sweeter
yeah that's good ah
i can only confirm that through finally
getting to hang out with like friends
and family after 18
you know however many months of saying
we would but i do think it makes it a
little sweeter
and um you you hit from something
interesting though annie which i hadn't
considered which is that you can be in
different places doing
like pursuing projects and still come
together in this way
from from my perspective i agree that it
is a bit democratizing and
uh i would have never gone to some of
the film festivals that i've been able
to watch movies at but
i i appreciate because you did just flag
for me a uh positive for the creatives
and i had been struggling to think
yeah no that's a i think that's a big
plus and i mean we have been working on
something
the three of us in different places and
so we are experiencing that a lot on
zoom and
it would be nice to be in the same room
i hope we have that
experience too but it's yeah i do think
it has like opened up a
different working space actually
that's an interesting thing i've i've
talked to some people
who are perhaps like me really shy or
not so great in a crowded room who
really love
doing stuff in this format have you guys
found that
it forces you to embrace a different
side of your creativity now that you're
working on a project together through a
digital screen i kind of love it i mean
i think
um i have collaborators that are
in different places and it's been really
great to be able to like schedule
meetings in this time and
do things over zoom obviously when we're
able to get together in person that's
great but i find that it actually
like in some ways helps with the focus
at least for me because it's
like you know when you're when you're on
zoom
i don't know something about it feels
more like this is the time to work
you know i think it's pretty good for
writing actually
yeah but like getting more into
production yeah it would be tricky not
to be there
i do really like like physical materials
and sort of like being able to look at
the same things together
sometimes like images and even though
all of
more and more that's sort of like on a
screen anyway but
um yeah i think it's kind of like it
um it just like is makes the
expedites the process of everything
going virtual for sure and
i mean just in a lot of ways the
pandemic has has
just uh kind of exacerbated
what was already happening and just like
sent us off in that direction of
just everything i mean i guess it cuts
down some travel time
i have uh saved many hours of my life in
la
not being in traffic la that's huge yeah
yeah
i have a very goofy question it i it was
just on my mind the whole movie have you
guys ever successfully
tricked people in switch places
not successfully but we did track once
in first grade
it was successful for a moment um but
then we turned ourselves in so we were
in
first grade and we basically were in the
same classroom
we're in the same homeroom so we just
switched desks
and then we got like a quiz
from the teacher and we like freaked out
because we were not sitting at the right
desk so we thought like we didn't have a
plan for like
was she going to write my name we're
really going to write hers we and also
all of our friends could always tell us
apart so even if like we got away with
it with a teacher like
when push came to shove like our friends
knew that we had switched so like they
were all looking to see what we were
going to do
we just all the people in our assigned
area knew that like we had switched
yeah so to wrap things up we do have two
questions that we
always ask our guests here and the first
one
is also kind of goofy but do you guys
have any pets
we actually grew up with a lot of pets
like when we were
younger we had like snakes and
chameleons
and like just like a crate like
dogs um we had like sugar gliders
at one point which were like flying
squirrels we have a lot of
exotic pets whenever my dad was taking
care of us
he would i mean like we were it was like
an activity one of the activities we
did together we did but one of the
activities we did together he would just
like
like yeah i think it was like in a if we
were like you know
he didn't know what we were going to do
next he'd be like let's go to the pet
store
he was just always very adventurous with
that like my poor mom would come home
for work and be like
what a chameleon now
um but right now i don't have any pets
which i'm sad about
i don't either i love animals i want a
pet so badly but
can't do it i don't know being in new
york in a very small apartment
me and my partner were considering well
we were just like googling
they're like these giant rap giant
flemish rabbits
they're like the size of a dog but
they're a rabbit
i think we like i don't think it's gonna
happen
but we were we were just throwing that
around the other day
the last question we always like to ask
our guests is uh
if anything within the genre whether
it's a
a book or a movie or a show and whether
you want a qualified genre as horror or
sci-fi whatever you love in genre
storytelling what's something you would
recommend our listeners go check out
after this
i recently rewatched the vanishing
the original it's a
dutch wait the filmmaker is um george
louiser i don't know if i'm butchering
his name but there's a remake but the
original i think is from the late 80s
and
it is just the scariest
i think it's like the best thriller ever
made um and i've
just thought of that because i recently
rewatched it and it's just
100 if you're looking for a great
thriller it's a little bit of a slow
burn but like it just
totally pays off in the end and it's so
great
one of my favorite endings of all time
one of my favorite films and to be very
clear
this only applies to the original don't
go on for me
i've been reading elena ferrante
recently i'm just like really
interested in reading um like female
driven stories that you know i guess
that the through line between superior
and elena ferrante is like there's
um the coming of age of a young woman
and
through a female perspective you just
like as
as a woman it's so it's just so nice
that you feel so like held
reading uh female voices
um especially with people who are
willing to be like as
uh vulnerable and like uh deal with
things as sensitively as
as elena ferrante so i am
mostly watching the sopranos right now
and i'm also on a bit of a
hall ashby kick yeah i i love
harold and mod and um
being there is really great that sounds
like a really
existential duo the sopranos and khalash
much to consider
well thank you guys so much for your
time it was such a pleasure
thank you to north bend film festival
for setting this up
if you are attending north bend film
festival definitely check out superior i
highly recommend it if you
are not keep an eye out for it because i
still highly recommend it
uh thank you guys so much it was such a
pleasure talking with you
thank you thank you likewise